ehi ciao
[Musica]
mi chiamo giancarlo curino e come penso
avete avuto modo di intuire sono un
vignettista satirico sono una persona
che parla poco e il mio mezzo
d'espressione principale è appunto il
disegno che se pensate bene e pensiamo
anche alle alle pitture rupestri nelle
caverne fatte dai giovani preistorici è
sempre stato il linguaggio espressivo
che l'uomo ha utilizzato per rispondere
al bisogno di comunicare
ho deciso di iniziare questo mio
intervento con delle mie opere che hanno
un sottile filo rosso che lega
se avete notato in ogni disegno manca il
balon i cosiddetti balloon questo per
significare come il disegno può
trasmettere un messaggio al di là della
presenza o meno di test scritti e di
parole e la satira e e questo io ho
iniziato a disegnare come un po penso
tutti voi
da bambino grazie ai miei genitori e mia
madre per premiarmi mi portava
all'edicola vicino casa e mi comprava
dei fumetti
io a casa e leggevo e poi amavo di
copiare i personaggi che erano presenti
nei fumetti
oltre ai personaggi mi piaceva ricopiare
anche quegli strani disegni che erano
presenti in copertina dei quotidiani i
giornali seri che portava a casa mio
padre
così ho conosciuto la satira e le
vignette satiriche e quindi i primi
autori vincino forattini altan a me
piaceva e dello sopportato dai miei
genitori anche capire quale del nesso
che collegava un'illustrazione a una
notizia
hanno notizie di attualità a quel
momento in poi ho sempre disegnato sono
andata avanti
ho cercato di affinare la tecnica
sceglievo anche autori preferiti
a un certo punto sono riuscito anche a
iniziare a pubblicare delle vignette su
quotidiani locali
io sono di caserta a scuola ero per
esempio il compagno di classe che tutti
chiedevano di fare una caricatura ai
professori
penso anche questo sia un'esperienza
comune ed era il primo momento in cui
iniziava a picconare il potere
disegnando appunto il professore il
potere gerarchico in classe c'è una cosa
che vi devo raccontare
iniziai a designare si le vignette sui
quotidiani locali però man mano la
voglia di fare salirà gradualmente
andava scemando
per due motivi fondamentali 1 perché
avevo intrapreso un percorso di studi
che poi mi ha portato a laurearmi in
architettura che un altro lato della mia
attività e poi un 8 motivo è che non
riconoscevo più e hanno detto anche i
ragazzi in precedenza nei quotidiani del
mio territorio in quanto c'era troppa
tra una cronaca nera e narrativa di
quello gara cronaca vera ma la satira
per me è rimasto fuoco sotto la cenere
perché successo un episodio che
conosciamo tutti che mi ha portato
nuovamente a fare satira e a
condividerla questo episodio tragico e
accaduto in un giorno preciso
era il 7 gennaio 2015 in un luogo
preciso che parigi in una mattinata
fredda invernale due uomini
incappucciati
provvisti di fucili d'assalto fecero
irruzione nella redazione di un giornale
di satira francese che charlie hebdo i
due uomini uccisero 12 persone tra cui
il direttore parte dei vignettisti della
rivista e anche due agenti di vigilanza
che erano lì per garantire la sicurezza
alla redazione che da anni era sotto
minaccia l'app di terrorismo contro
charlie hebdo per me non fu solo un atto
di violenza contro la redazione di un
giornale ma bensì per me era un atto
terroristico contro la libertà di
espressione
da qui la voglia di ricominciare a fare
savera e quindi dopo il 7 gennaio 2015
ho creato un mio blog ho incominciato a
pubblicare nuovamente vignette ea
condividerle per me che cos'è la satira
la santità e il bambino che nella famosa
favola indicai che culo e il termometro
che misura il grado di democrazia di un
popolo e di una società
io come vignettista penso di offrire a
chi sfoglia un giornale oppure partecipa
a una mostra uno lo spunto per
riflettere su una determinata notizia a
volte molti mi chiedono ma la santità ha
dei confini fino al 20 si può spingere
io penso che la satira non ha confini
io colafati io parlo di tutto posso
parlare di stragi di stato
posso parlare di problemi legati al
mondo del lavoro
posso parlare di vita quotidiana quindi
edilizia scolastica posso parlare anche
di problemi legati al nostro territorio
posso parlare anche di religione e di
società posso parlare anche di problemi
e questioni attuali come la migrazione
posso naturalmente parlare di politica e
posso toccare anche argomenti come la
morte
possiamo spingerci ovunque in ogni
ambito
ma noi dobbiamo stare attenti ad usare
soltanto ea rispettare soltanto una sola
regola che ogni vignettista col fisico
come me come potete vedere deve tatuarsi
in petto ed è che la satira colpisce il
potere la satira deve colpire con una
nazione univoca verso l'alto verso il
vertice della piramide gerarchica per
aiutare a a trasmettervi l'idea di
satira e mi è venuto in aiuto il
personaggio di perseo che ho incontrato
naturalmente al di là della scuola
leggendo un libro di dollaro al vino che
sono che si intitola la lezione
americana perseo e lo conosciamo tutti è
il mostro è l'eroe che ha ucciso il
mostro medusa la satira in questo in
quest'immagine da cosa è rappresentata
la satira è lo scudo di di perseo
io quando e lavoro le mie vignette
non pretendo di dire le affermazione una
verità la mia le mie vignette vogliono
essere un punto di domanda e io le
lavoro cercando di deformare la realtà
la satira per me un filtro con cui
vedere ciò che mi sta attorno
e l'eroe perseo è riuscito ad ammazzare
a tagliare la testa della medusa
grazie all'immagine riflessa nel suo
scudo ma una volta che perseo ha ucciso
medusa dopo come continua la storia ce
la racconta e con questo mi leggo anche
al tema di stasera che cambiamento c'e
racconto video video appunto nelle sue
metamorfosi racconta che naturalmente
per sé aveva la testa di medusa in una
mano ed è un'immagine e iconografica che
conosciamo tutti
basta sfogliare un libro di storia
dell'arte o video racconta che il primo
istinto che ebbe che ebbe per creo fu
quella di lavarsi le mani forse un
istinto che che tutti avrebbero quelle
di pulirsi del sangue del mostro
allora cosa fare scende al sulla riva
del mare vicino all'altro di medusa
l'atessa la poteva accettare
tranquillamente da qualche parte oppure
buttarla sul bagnasciuga
ma fa un gesto molto di una gentilezza
rinfrescante raccoglie ramoscelli marini
e alghe e con la mano libera
naturalmente e crea una sorta di cuscino
vegetale su cui perseo adagia la testa
del mostro
naturalmente per preservarsi dallo
sguardo pietrificante del mostro
appoggia col viso di medusa verso il
basso
e cosa succede succede un miracolo
i ramoscelli diventano vengono
pietrificati è così o video racconta
come nasce il corallo perseo l'eroe
sconfigge il mostro con un gesto di
grande gentilezza fa nascere un miracolo
un miracolo che è condiviso infatti
video continuato a contare che le ninfe
accorrevano alla spiaggia portando
ognuna delle alghe dei ramoscelli per
sottoporle allo sguardo del mostro è
quindi per far creare nuovo corallo con
cui adornarsi la sfida di un vignettista
satirico oggi è legata molto alla
pubblicazione dei propri lavori g non le
vignette non vengono più pubblicate
vengono pubblicate sui giornali
istituzionale ma la crisi di dettori ha
ormai la rampante ascesa delle
piattaforme digitali e del web fa sì che
possiamo vedere sui canali social in
internet vignette oppure fotomontaggi
secondo me basta basate su una
cattiveria e sul un cinismo imperante
che suggeriscono anche commenti a di
altrettanto basso livello
allora io penso che la sfida per me sia
quella di ricordare il gesto gentile che
ha fatto perseo per cui io mi auguro e
vi auguro di essere come lui come perseo
1 cesari di mostri ma preservando sempre
il proprio animo gentile
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]